the Batman and Robin because like Joker
even when you're trying to agree you're
not agreeing
[Music]
all right who here used to watch the old
animated Batman cartoons oh yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah with Mark Hamill is the Joker
yeah oh yeah Mark Hamill actually just
explained why he won't voice The Joker
again anymore why not that sucks anybody
know no because Kevin does it hurt his
throat no no yes because of Kevin conr
just recently passed the Batman oh he
passed 2022. and the thing is they
weren't just let me see I got to get the
uh so he needs that Batman voice so he
could do the Joker voice because he's
this is not the same he always played
opposite you know what I mean that
Batman so like their voices always went
together and it wasn't just Batman the
Animated Series it was also the 1993 uh
animated film Batman mask of the
Phantasm oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and then
also 2016's Batman The Killing Joke
anybody oh The Killing Joke is amazing
I don't remember also oh also
rocksteady's Batman Arkham series video
games yeah his voice Mark Hamill and
Kevin Connor always came back and they
always had like that specific Duo and
now that Kevin passed away Markham was
like I can't do it anymore that's really
dope that's probably good I have a good
Contender um we should have Jimmy
Kimmel's Guillermo because when he did
his Batman it was really good yeah it
was really good he has no Guillermo yeah
he's great he'd say I am the Batmans it
was good you guys don't agree is that
the dog
no I'm tripping never mind
Guillermo's the security guard the
Mexican security guard the guy who has
the [__] dog Jimmy Kimmel I think
it's Jimmy Kimmel yeah Jimmy Kimmel all
right Jimmy Kimmel guys
no that's Guillermo del Toro
foreign
does anybody else know any other [__]
like uh kind of like that partner Duo
that like cannot be separated it cannot
be and like adversarial Anthony Lee and
Mike song
they gotta be like against each other
like Joker and Batman yeah yeah who
caught back up right
that's true I don't know who compliments
each other I didn't even think about
that though I don't even remember George
and Arnold Schwarzenegger
Mr Freeze Mr Freeze yeah yeah George
Clooney yeah yeah yeah that was good
that's a good one that's my favorite one
are Batman and Joker the most notorious
arch nemesis still like yeah all the
time yeah I think so because the goal of
Batman was never to kill Joker yeah it
was just like its counterpart so he
could never truly like end him yeah and
they need each other in a weird sense
and that yeah yeah yeah exactly it's
like Chaos and Order you have to have
one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah if you
can't have one you can't have the other
mm-hmm yeah what comes in second what's
like even close as like a icon Tom and
Jerry no that's true yeah yeah looser
and coyote oh yeah about top of Jerry
they're actually friends like they're
not like he's only chasing the mouse and
uh what is it Jerry or Tom which was the
Tom's a cat Jerry uh lets him chase him
so that uh Tom has a job to do so they
don't kick the cat out because like
that's why wow so so they're actually
playing all the time I like it who told
you this love is this just like [__]
no no no no they're actually friends
there's there's like episodes where
they're like oh you they're hugging
their buddies you know you ever watched
a movie they're like I did not watching
they were always friends you ever seen
episodes where he thinks he killed them
and then he starts crying
those ones yeah and he tries to like
bring it back that's why it's Tom and
Jerry not Tom versus yeah that makes
sense
Looney Tunes always pissed me off as a
child why why because I can see the
whole thing playing out and I'm all like
it never you never catch him anyway you
can't not gonna fool me this time and I
just watched the whole thing and I'm
like you feel jipped Albert [__]
never [__] especially the Roadrunner
I'm like why you keep chasing them he's
gonna run he's gonna get away he's gonna
get away you suck you're acting [__]
never works yeah Peter Pan and Captain
Hook I am that's true that's a good one
that's a good one yeah that is good I
think a lot of Disney movies are like
that yeah because you can't kill anybody
exactly
but in those ones the villain does kind
of lose you know what I mean or at least
tell the sequel and then he's back yeah
he never dies plank did dude SpongeBob
and Plankton yeah yeah that's a good one
we can't be going from Batman and Joker
is that Squidward input SpongeBob no
they're friends do you remember how The
Killing Joke ends uh yes do you remember
like so it's it's assumed that at the
end of The Killing Joke boiler alert
yeah spoiler alert that it doesn't show
it and it doesn't explicitly say it but
it's to be assumed that Batman kills
Joker after the end really it's pretty
cool except it actually doesn't happen
it doesn't actually happen it's just in
the title but then all those movies are
different universes that's true who's
that who is this it's Bart hurry up dude
come inside you didn't text me are you
guys filming
[Applause]
did you watch Batman the Animated Series
of course yeah yeah The Dark Knight
After
Dark Knight Afters huh the dark night
after is that like the morning who do
you think he's like yeah Plan B who do
you think is the best oh yes filming of
course yeah I thought you guys taking a
breakouts this is so quiet just dude we
were thinking about some of us are
trying to run your company still
who okay who do you think is the best
hero and villain Duo
the best because there because Anthony
says that Batman and Joker is like the
top most notoriously iconic most iconic
where one can't exist without the other
I would say wait who's is is Superman's
Lex Luthor Lex Luthor or is it
Kryptonite nah kryptonite's like a thing
that's like drugs you know what I would
like to say I would I think I would like
to think it's actually Lois Lane Lois
Lane is is the villain yeah what because
that [__] too strong bro yeah it's too
strong that's his real kryptonite yeah
am I right that's his real kryptonite
am I right I think I have to agree with
Anthony what the Batman and Robin
because like Joker
even when you're trying to agree you're
not agree
Batman and [__] Joker like Joker is
the he's the only villain that actually
knows the inner workings of the
superhero and he plays the puppet with
him
you know what I mean like he knows that
okay this guy will never kill me yeah so
because of that I can push my boundaries
I don't think any other Duo where the
villain actually knows the inside of the
superhero there's no other dude that
challenges each other yeah because the
other one else is just I just want to be
the greatest I want to be the more
powerful I want to rule the world
they're not like I know the inside of
your brain that's scary you know don't
you think Mark Hamill oh actually there
is one this is nerd alert but there is
but there's also Captain America in Red
Skull that are trapped in limbo forever
to like fight each other oh
that's a big time nerd alert yeah but if
Captain America dies uh what's that
fool's name again Red Skull Red Skull
we'll just continue we'll just continue
in in the in in one version of the
comics they basically get trapped in
limbo and then they're because they're
of equal strength with the same
superhero serum type [__] yeah but he'll
just continue to rule the world no but
they don't die they're in limbo fighting
each other for eternity types because I
think Joker would actually be sad he's
like [__] he was my greatest puppet they
would both be sad like there's no one
that challenges me yeah don't you think
the people of Gotham are like Jesus
Christ please just kill him already oh
my God Batman what the [__] like my my
dad's dead kill Joker why is it he's
still coming out of jail my dad can't
stop smiling kill the guy oh my God
people are dying people are dying please
kill him I want to see another hospital
where like Batman loses control right
he's like oh my [__] I'll kill you
I'm so [__] sorry
but yeah I think that everyone else is
like dude [__] Joker dude kill him kill
him yeah I don't like that Batman's a
[__] dude Batman's pretty ineffective
he's like a California Rail Project
that's just never getting done
like apple Goes to Jail Joker Goes to
Jail
I feel like Batman has an identity
crisis without Joker yeah
but he got other people he got [__] I
was like Sandman clock King I mean uh
scarecrow Sandman the penguin what about
the best
you got Dr freeze you got [__] oh
you're thinking of you're thinking of
Clayface
he got Bane Joker I just Googled a bunch
of greatest Arch enemies of all time oh
yeah thank you y'all [__] suck I bet
you Ip Man versus Japan
versus Mike Tyson
versus the country
you versus imperialism so we got we got
Superman Lex Luthor we talked about that
Bruce Lee versus Japan they always make
it like I know a little Empire because
to them those were the Nazis so we got
this guy's laughing the Japanese we got
Sherlock Holmes Versus Professor
Moriarty who the [__] is that nerd alert
I didn't know
we got Optimus Prime versus Megatron oh
yeah that's good that's true except
Megatron dies in the movie spoiler alert
they should just [__] each other dude
we've got a lot of alerts today you guys
are in love with each other
[Laughter]
I don't know they found me but they
found me the libyans
basically this article also had a
difficult time coming up with yeah yeah
Harry Potter Lord Voldemort Obi-Wan
Kenobi vs Darth Maul not not Batman a
Joker Batman and Joker is just the best
there's got to be some that are number
one they're number one I think they
[__] up by having uh the name Red
Skull for Captain America I think they
should have called them comrade
communist yeah that'd be a fire that's
nice that would have been more of a
catchy like because it's America versus
communism you know oh uh John Q and the
insurance industrial complex how did I
not think of that that's true that's a
big one
emphasized himself
or skin
[Music]
foreign